[音楽]
一般の方が自分の睡眠ですねまあ簡単に
改善できるっていうふうなことをまあ今日
は2つお話したいと思いますひとつは体温
なんですねえ体温っていうのは私たちは
いうのは体の中の温度で昼間が高くて夜が
低いそれはパフォームポストも非常に創刊
しているんですね
夜冬体温が下がらないと良い睡眠が訪れ
ないということもわかっているんですね
対応の常設というのは熱を作る方と熱を見
がそうなんですね
熱をつくるって言ったら昼間体を動かした
時を無駄昇進ですけどまぁか筋肉や四郎
やまないぞからも熱でと出るんですけど
それで昼間がもん体温が高い
で夜は体温が下がるんですねその時には
主に手足ですね
皮膚の表面で特に手足には毛細血管が発達
していてそこで体の中の温度と同じ血流が
即の表明流れるのでラジエーターのように
そこから熱が逃げていくんですねそれで熱
が下がるでそれで例えば完母を見て
いただいたらわかると思うんですけど眠い
ときてが使ったりほっぺたが赤いですね
その後体温が下がっているんですね
だからそういう変化を上手く利用すればね
つぎが早くなるそれから入眠食に深い睡眠
が出るということもわかっているんですね
で例えば日本人の場合お風呂
od をするということがであるんですね
阪神北
でお風呂だった逆じゃないかと言われるか
もしれないんですけど今な話と
ただまぁお風呂に例えば
15分40度くらいのお風呂に入ると体の
中の温度0.5トレイ転読と一時的に
上がるんですけどもそれがまあまあある
時間をかけて元に戻る
で実際のデータなんですけどそういう条件
で私たちのデータでは
90分ぐらいかかってるんですね
でその90分間は体が火照って眠れないん
ですけどその後どうなるかといえばお風呂
に入ってない時よりも体の中の温度が
下がるんですね
だからそのタイミングで布団に入ると速く
滑るそれから深い青民が訪れるって言う
ことがわかっているんですね
それがまあ一つ体温の調節のことなんです
けどもう一つ大事なのは脳のスイッチと
いうことで
寝る前はできるだけ
まあ頭を使わない日ラックスするっていう
ことが大事なんですね
で
夜眠れない眠れないってまぁ
訴える方多いんですけどよく調べると朝
からの生活に問題があったりするんですね
だから朝は逆に正且創生あげる朝ごはんも
大事なんですね
それから
日光の光を浴びる
でまあ人間の固有のリズムっていうのは
24時間長女強度ではなくて24時間より
も長いですね
だから特に今コロナのようなリモート
ワークの時には後ろ後ろ何ていく傾向が
あって
ま寝る時間が遅くなってすい3時間も長く
なるんだけど質が悪くなるそういったが
ことを予防するためには朝から体に朝です
よっていうことを知らせて活動を上げて
いく
逆にまあ夕方ですねまあ夕食後が薄めバー
まあできるだけ
まあリラックスをしてまー証明なんかも
そうなんですけどもリラックスをしてね
ブルー準備をするそういったメリハリが
大事だということになると思います
で特にいまー最近コンピューターを使って
web であるとか e メールですね
そういうことを見ると例えば寝る前に一つ
まあ
腹立つようなメールが来とそれだけでも
まあ何時間もむか包むん看過するとかいう
こともあるのでそういうことは良くないと
言うことになるんですね
だからまあ生活習慣になるんですけども
睡眠というのはいろんなことの影響を受け
ているので改善する余地を剥いロイはある
んですね
だから今言ったようなことを気をつけて
いただいてそれ以外にも例えば厚生労働省
ですねまあ
自由に過剰っていうふうなことをまあ今
言ったことともうバーアップするんです
けど
まあそういう指針もあるのでそういった
ことを参考臣民しながら色々試されて中文
にあったものを続けるということが大事だ
と思います
最近興味があるっていうのは職場の
パフォーマンスなんですね
まぁ最近健康経営とかよく言われるんです
けども注目されている言葉としてプレゼン
ティーズ6という言葉があります
それはまあ職場には来てるんですけども
まぁ効率よく仕事ができないという風な
状態でだから以前は阿武山てぃずむですね
速弾き決起まあ目に見える形が多いんです
けどそういうことをまあ目に見えるという
こともあって対策は講じられてきたんです
けど
人コーヒーからすればその職場に来て
まあいろんな疾患があるとか体調が悪いと
かそういったことで
効率よく最大限パフォーマンス発揮でき
ないというような状態ですね
それでまあ特に最近なんですけどそういっ
た職場のパフォーマンスに睡眠が非常に
大きく影響しているって言うことがわかっ
てきたんですね
で睡眠はまあ
よくすればまあ
実感リスクですね色んな疾患のリスクが
下がるって言うことをわかってたんです
けど
パフォーマンス特に職場のパフォーマンス
が
最近注目されています
でそれで私が一つやっぱり強調したいこと
はまあそういった睡眠改善を行えばまあ
多くの人がパフォーマンス上がることを
間違えないんですけども
睡眠障害級の非常に頻度が多いので
でよく私たちよく使う言葉は
睡眠は非常に壊れやすい
フラジャイルっていう言葉で強い者注意
ですねだから例えば部屋の温度が熱すぎる
とか湿度が高いとか寝れないですねで
もちろん心配事があっても寝れないで体の
ドッグ歯が痛くてもねぇないということ
ですねだからその睡眠障害というのは非常
に頻度が多いですね例えば睡眠時無呼吸
症候群ですねそういった病気はやはりまあ
適切に診断されてチリを ok の専門医
の治療ですね受けないとそういった改善
プログラムでよくなる者でないということ
ですね
だからえまあそういうことをやはり経営者
の方ですね
も理解していただいて
治療が受ける疾患は
専門医の治療を受けて
でそれで多くの社員ですね
版まあ健康合計
パフォーマンスを上げるということは大事
なんですけどの中に一つ
睡眠が大大切であるということになります
それでまあどういう風なアプローチをすれ
ばいいかということなんですけど
一つ参考になるのがそれも米国で始まった
ことなんですけど
ミンチ行動療法ですねね認知行動療法と
言ったらまあうつ病とかまぁ他の疾患でも
いう個性が確立されているんですけどまぁ
民商でもそういった試みがなされるという
ことででどういうことかといったらまず一
つ
睡眠がどのように調節されているか生理学
的な知識であると海が来てきた知識ですね
で
それがまあ身につけてまあ誤った情報まあ
特に日本で
まあ
蔓延しているので
そういった正しい知識を身につけるそれ
から特に睡眠のことなんですけどまぁ何も
かも睡眠のせいにする人へ行ってるんです
ねだから今日うまくいかないのは
昨日眠れなかったからだで実際よく眠れて
いるのに全然眠れないとか
誤った認識ですねそういったことをただ
すっていうことも大事なんですね
でもう一つ
まあ行動療法のになるんですけどまぁ誤っ
た行動を正すということですねで例えば
よく言われものはベッドの中はまめるため
にあるだからベッドの中でた手本を見ると
かテレビを見るっていくの良くないという
こということででそれでまあいろいろな
まぁことを試してもいいと思うんですけど
自分にとって良い睡眠とってよ1週間を
続けるということが大事でそれで一つ自分
によかっても人に勧めてもまあ個人差が
あるのでうまくいかないこともあるんです
ね
だからまあ良い一週間は覚えておいて
続けるでそれでええまあいろいろ試して
上手くいかなかったことは続ける必要が
ないということですねそういうことは人
から勧められても合わないことがあったら
続ける必要がないということになります
私の睡眠に関してのまあ気をつけてほトっ
ていうのは一つは眠くなったら逆らうずに
寝るということなんですねなかなかは皆が
そういった環境っていうか許せる状況に
やるとは思えないんですけども眠たい時に
いいいるとやはり
深い睡眠が出るんですね睡眠あつって言う
言葉使うんですけど水3月が集ったか待っ
ていると記念笛ば破壊セミが出る
それで対面を逃すと逆に眠れなくなったり
するんですねで特にまあ高齢になってくる
ともともと睡眠チタンが分散化してきてで
私よくいうことなんですけどまぁ
ガッシュの若い時の睡眠自分の睡眠ですね
それと比べて睡眠がどうかっていうのは
あんまりへ比較しても意味がなくて睡眠も
悩みも持たれている方は特にみまー同年代
の人と比べて自分の睡眠がどえどの程度で
あるかということ大事なんですねそういう
ことを考えると例えばある恒例になってき
て夜中に3回起きて研いでいくというのは
当然で
睡眠が分断化してくる
それでまあ
年振るタイミングっていうのはのが
セイバーなかなか寝れないということです
ねそういう意味でまあ分散睡眠ということ
版もあるんですね分散水3分割意味ですね
それどういうことかといったら例えばまあ
有名な人であればスティーブンジョブス
なんかもそうなんですけど夜の睡眠て4
時間くらいなんですけど
20短い睡眠ですね場合によって30分1
時間ですねそれを3回4回とるっていうな
ことででその後マディフレッシュされ
るっていう風な事でまあ1日まあ
詰めて
でそのチューチューして働くて言うよりも
そういうふうに今分割して睡眠をとれば
その後まあ集中できるっていうなことです
それでまあみんなにそういうことを進める
ことわけにはいかないかもしれないんです
けど
例えば一つ
そういった利点っていうのは
し明記木があったような時ですね
明日あさってまで
そういったときにお腹を着て正
そういった作業ができ売っているなことと
それからもう一つ時差ボケの時にもまあ1
時間ね時間眠る眠い時に寝るっていう事を
は離島効果的なんですねそれは自験例なん
ですけどだからまあ特に高齢になってきた
場合まとまっている長い睡眠がとれない
ような時には無理に逆らわず3
少しまあ起きて a 軽作業をする昼間が
眠くなった時にはねるっていうのも現在品
として一つの対処方法かなっているふうに
思っています
私をぞ増えたことがあったのはアメリカの
nh の
研究申請グラントですね
そのレビューにまあいいん教えたことが
あったんですね
でそれは結構激務でその怪異まぁ夜の飛行
機の便で行ったりするんですね
翌日会議があるので1番まあ研究申請の
書類を選んで1日会議があるんですね
でだから合計30時間以上も寝てないん
ですけどそういうふうに頭を興奮させて
しまうと全くその後目でないんですね
でだからやはりまあ
そういう眠るためにはそういったメリハリ
ピューかー
緊張とマカンはというかリラックスという
ことが大事で
でそういった眠気が訪れた時にそれを逃せ
ば寝れないっていうふうなことはまああと
ままありますね
自宅の場合にはもう
例えば家でまぁお客さんが入った場合でも
そのまあ少し眠開くてへ親切にくっていう
ふうなことですねそういうことがまあ遺伝
はなんかそれが失礼だと思ってたんです
けど最近
まあ
まあそれが大事だと言うまあ
パフォーマンスとかでまぁ自分の健康にも
大事だということであまりまぁ気にせず
まあそういう今宿がを倒すってておかしい
んですけどまぁ自分のスタイルでっていう
ふうなことがまぁ最近
多いというかまぁ
許されるというふうな状況ですね
それから私アメリカ生活が長いので日本で
仕事くることが多いですね
それで夜の会食とかいうのも時間的に言え
ば夜中の3時4時とかででそれがやはり
かなり負担になる時があるんですねその時
はまあ自分に言い聞かせるわけですけども
まぁ解説を断っても昼間の正
仕事ですか
会議であるとかそれをきちっとすればまあ
解析でその
料理を食べて雑談してはお酒を飲むこと
よりもより中重要でないかというような事
でそういう事でまああまりこだわらない
ようになりまし
睡眠って言えば毎日の事ですねで時間すれ
ば人生の3分の1ですね
だから味方につけると非常に心強いんです
けど敵に回せは手ごわいということですね
でそういったことで特にクリエイティブな
仕事をしている人ですね睡眠時間を削って
多いことはないと思いますだから十分な
睡眠をとってよりよい生活人生を送って
いただきたいと思います